before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
all right
one bit of Unfinished Business
yes I know I said the last video was uh
the end of Wednesday videos but uh I
almost forgot
I gotta rank the 13th doctor's era not
the whole thing rather my top 10. what I
think is the best of an area
what do I think was the best of an era
that didn't usually do a lot for me well
you're about to find out and allow me to
spoil something right off the bat uh
Hanukkah Villa diadari is not on this
list I know that is the one that the
fandom has collectively decided is the
good one of uh this run
under Jody Whitaker and Chris chimno but
uh I have really big issues with it if
you don't know what they are there's the
video check it out it won't come up here
I'm talking about stuff I actually do
like so let's get started
number 10.
the ghost Monument
this was kind of a pick-me-up for me
after not fully feeling great about the
woman who fell to Earth this is not an
exceptional episode but it has the feel
it has the energy it has the sense of
adventure that I like from Doctor Who in
general and I really liked from this era
when it did it and I think that this was
an episode that captured it quite well I
like just the uh constant moving forward
the sense of like we got to keep going
it has momentum that I really enjoy I
actually quite like the villain and how
they don't actually get to defeat him
and he's just dismissively like yeah I'm
not gonna help you and then he's gone I
actually love that I even like the weird
uh deadly scarf things because that's
weird and bizarre and like who the hell
thinks of that I don't know an alien
mind coming up with weapons that doesn't
think the way humans think that's who
comes up with that I dig it I just enjoy
this
number nine
Nikola Tesla's Knight of Terror this is
one that I had to re-watch to get a
greater appreciation of it it kind of
went in one ear and out the other uh
first time I watched it re-watching it
though that's a lot more to this than I
gave her credit for before first of all
it's got some really good guest
performances as well as the core cast
doing pretty dang good work as well it
has that sense of adventure that the
ghost Monument also has so that's a big
bonus for me I feel like it uh in many
ways it handles the historical elements
better than Doctor Who often does it
doesn't feel quite as much of a
Wikipedia entry just reciting everything
about these people we get to see Tesla
and Edison just exist as people it's one
of the better historical episodes of
this era and I'm not big on historical
episodes in the first place but this one
this one grew on me I really came to
appreciate it on the second viewing
number eight
revolution of the Daleks the second of
the Dalek New Year's Eve special Trilogy
like first of all I'll just fess up
you're gonna see all three parts of this
Trilogy on here this is the one that
comes in the lowest partly because the
stuff with Chris noth's character is not
really adding all that much I'm not just
saying that because the guy turned out
to not be a particularly great human
being but honestly the character doesn't
add a ton I could also argue Jack
doesn't add all that much speaking of
people who turned out to be not great
human beings but at least Jack is fun in
this and it's a continuation on the
reconnaissance dialect which I actually
really like and I've always liked in
general the infighting between dialects
I like when that comes up and that's
here as well so it also has that energy
and that sense of momentum that as I've
said repeatedly already in this list the
server didn't always happen but when it
did
it really worked
number seven
fugitive of the je Dune this probably
would have ranked higher if you know the
fugitive doctor had actually gone
anywhere but ultimately even revisiting
it and knowing that this is effectively
just an abandoned storyline for all
intents and purposes
I still enjoy it
a lot of that having to do with the
fugitive doctor herself Joe Martin is
really good in this part like really
good she's phenomenal she is so
commanding and such Charisma I'm really
excited for her to do big finish if RTD
ever wants to bring her back and do
something please please I would be so
here for that
she does a lot to elevate this and even
that aside structurally it's pretty well
put together but there's a good
misdirect with you thinking that it's
our partner that you do and are after
but then it turns out to be her and we
find out who she is and her behavior
like she's got just enough of that
Essence like yeah you are the doctor but
you're a very different doctor from the
one we're currently dealing with
it does just have a really fun energy to
it but it does in many ways feel like a
part one to something that never got a
proper part two
not this episode's fault but does still
bring it down a little bit
number six
resolution the first of the New Year's
Eve special on New Year's Day special
whatever the Dalek specials the first
one this is what introduced the
reconnaissance dialogue and I like the
reconnaissance dialect a lot
it's creepy the way it's piloting people
and using them pretty much as puppets
but like they're not completely taken
over and at times trying to even fight
against it but it just doesn't work and
does it throw together its own tank
casing pretty quickly yeah
but I think it works again because it
has that energy and it has the momentum
and I I like bringing it back down to
the doctor versus a single Dalek not a
fleet not a complete Army of the thing
just one
it's a reminder that these things even
one of them is extremely dangerous and I
like it for that as well in addition to
everything else going on that I enjoy
there are problems here and there I've
talked about them in the reviews
specifically talking about this but
when it isn't having a few stumbles it's
it's quite good
number five
Demons of the Punjab
this is a very good historical episode
partly for talking about a period of
history that while the uh the UK is very
much responsible for in many ways is an
aspect of History well I can't say
whether or not it's talked about much in
the UK it's not talked about much in the
US and bringing it down to the ground
level and dealing with its impact on
people
Ordinary People
I think in general I find the historical
settings work better when they deal with
historical events but not historical
figures
so that we can focus on just getting to
know these characters in this situation
without worrying about are we honoring
or getting all the key information in on
this historical figure and it just feels
more natural more lived in more earned
this has a really wonderful heart at its
Center and it is about the bonds that
pull us together but also what happens
when they snap and when they snap hard
enough
to leave lasting damage
this is a really good one
number four
it takes you away
this to me might well be the Pinnacle of
just freaking weird Doctor Who
and I like freaking weird Doctor Who
it hasn't been this kind of What the
Hell in a while I can't remember the
last time it was just this offhandedly
casually bizarre
but I really like it
because in a universe that is this
infinite why can't you have a tunnel
passage connecting two realities with
moths that eat flesh but not clothing
that connects to a sentient universe
that's also a frog
is that absolutely
insane yes and I love it
there are some issues with the
characterization of some of the guest
cast and
what the episode is trying to say about
grief is quite nice how much it succeeds
that that is uh it's a little bit of a
mixed bag but
the stuff that is good about this is
also almost unique to this this is good
and hits me in a way that very few
episodes of Doctor Who do this or any
other era
when a show can be bold enough to be
this weird
it just makes me so happy
number three
Eve of the Daleks it's Dalek Groundhog
Day
and it's a lot of fun
Doctor Who has not done time Loops
nearly as often as you would think
but this is a neat idea it's a neat
conceit and I like the idea that the
time Loop is shrinking so that they
can't just keep trying this infinitely
until they get it right they'll get more
chances but they're on the clock as well
and the dialects are there they're
threatening and there is just a light
enough touch and feel you have those
Groundhog Day moments of realizing oh
well we can take them all again on this
one we can't do that every time but we
can on this one and doctor having this
rousing speech of like we failed we and
we try again we fail again but better
and like does the rising speech and then
immediately the next Loop they get
gunned down almost immediately
this just has a really great energy to
it and again it has that propellant
nature that momentum that I deeply
appreciate and it's just a good time
number two
can you hear me
I know that I praise this one a hell of
a lot more than actually anybody else
that I know
some people don't like
what it's saying or how it says it
some people have very different reads on
certain parts of this than I do I won't
necessarily try and claim that the
episode is unimpeachable or above
critique but what I can tell you is that
I stick very firmly to my read of this
episode of what it is saying of what it
is doing of the nature of these god-like
beings that pit societies against
themselves how that parallels with
depression how it parallels with that
sense that your mind is at war with
itself for the benefit of something that
just wants nothing but harm for you the
weirdness again much like it takes you
away just this guy whose fingers come
off that's freaking weird and I love it
I like the metaphor the analogy or at
least how I choose to read it I even
like that last scene with graham other
people don't I do again I like my read
on it
I'm not going to say that my read is
correct in other people's isn't
but I have read this episode in a way
that makes me love it and re-watching
this now multiple times
has done nothing but reinforce my read
on this
whether or not my read on this as a
metaphor for depression as an
examination of these things of the
doctors seen with graham as being an
extension of the fact that she is not
able to relate to people but her telling
him I'm gonna go through this these
actions and then Circle back and say
what I should have said in the first
place is her version of letting him in
because she can't stop herself from
doing the weird alienating thing but she
can at least warn him that she's about
to do it
this is my read on this and through the
lens that I view this episode I really
love it but despite it having ranked the
highest other times that I've done
things vaguely related to this and other
statements I made before
it actually is not at number one as I
was expecting it to be
number one
the power of the doctor
this is just so joyous
so
excited
so in love with
the history of the doctor arguably with
its own error I mean bringing back
characters like vendor and Assad The
Fugitive doctor even who don't really
need to be there they're there as a
celebration of this era but it's also a
celebration of a Doctor Who's a whole
with the classic doctors coming in and
the thing is
every other episode on this list nearly
I well
yeah no every other episode on this list
I can go okay but there is this even
with can you hear me which I love I will
still say Okay so the wrap up was a
little rushed at the end
I don't really have a major reservation
for this
that's not to say that's perfect it's
not there's a lot of logistical things
you get hung up on and if the
celebratory feel of the whole thing is
not connecting with you it can feel
really indulgent and almost sort of
insulting like hey remember this and
you're just sitting there going yeah I
do and I don't care so if the
celebratory feel of it doesn't wrap you
up in its energy then yeah maybe this
doesn't work for you but it wraps me up
and it's managed to do that on repeat
viewings it didn't fade I still watch
this with a massive smile on my face
whether it is Jody Whitaker's doctor and
her marvelous closing line tag Lauren
Joe Martin as a fugitive doctor getting
one more triumphant moment doesn't mean
anything for her overall character Arc
do we know much more about her no but
it's still just felt good to see her
again to see Ace with the baseball bat
to see Tegan get to confront the fifth
doctor kind of call him out on his
nonsense are these cheap pops maybe I
don't care
I don't care
if it works it works
a win is a win
this works this is a win I really enjoy
it I liked it even more revisiting it
and I think it's probably the one I am
most likely to come back to and re-watch
for pleasure
power of the doctor
this was a rocky era
but it finished real well
what do you think of this list what's
your top ten how much do you disagree
with mine whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it patreon pays the
bills enables me to do this as my living
even if you can't help me out that way
like share subscribe are also of great
assistance but don't worry too much
about it
what I really want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council and I am just
running the meetings and until next time
this Council
is adjourned
[Music]
and now my thanks my patreon supporters
to make this possible including Robin
Moore Zubin look fulla to rock the thing
that goes dunk in the anime Ruth Oliver
B solitary pictures
Ulrich bogdon Linda Walters Janet t love
Auntie Kate 808 Barnaby likes the poodle
Robin Powell Tracy scrabot angry Casper
Adam RDL Taylor Dave Hall Shayla gourlay
and Rosalind Bennett
you can get uh my the bat I get all the
names right and then I can't talk if you
want to hear me stumble over my tongue
after saying your name it's in the
rewards here on the patreon
[Music]
thank you